let's just pick up on the issue of the
conflict between armenia and azerbaijan
we were just mentioning it with samuel
green now foreign ministers of both
countries
are holding talks on moscow to resolve
the week's long border conflict over
nagorno-karabakh
this is the latest effort to end the
worst flare-up in violence between the
two for over a quarter of a century
armenia's leader is saying he is ready
to resume peace talks
but the azeri president seems to be
backing a military solution to the
conflict for now
senem kosovo is live in azerbaijan
that's where the president addressed the
nation earlier today
first we'll bring in journalist
alexandra stoyanovic god freud she's
joining us from moscow
on the russian mediation efforts they're
still going on
what are we hearing about the expected
outcome
yes this negotiations the first direct
talks uh between any officials of
armenia and azerbaijan since the
conflict
started are entering their fifth hour
now and now
the goal that was uh voiced
ahead of this ahead of this meeting is
actually not very high
is to basically achieve a truth a
ceasefire
a humanitarian kind that the
bodies of the killed ones can be
collected and also
exchange of prisoners could happen now
that is probably because
on anything else there could not agree
uh
so they could not there were calls for
cease for immediate ceasefire to going
back to the negotiation tables from
all the uh co-chairs of the osce men's
group so
russia france and united states but that
didn't work
so now we were told they are actually to
talk
about the possibility of ceasefire to
exchange prisoners and to collect
the deceased now these talks happen
after
hours of phone calls of russian
president vladimir putin
with the heads of state of armenia and
azerbaijan
and they're here on his invitation an
invitation that
one uh cannot refuse now as as you said
uh our armenian prime minister ahead of
this talk said that armenia is ready to
renew negotiation process but he also
later said that what armenia is facing
is
azeri turkish aggression on romanian
people and that
people in karabakh are actually close to
humanitarian catastrophe
he also said that armenia is still
thinking about recognizing
nagorno-karabakh and that
also other countries should do that now
this is something that
we know is unacceptable for for
azerbaijan
and what we saw the previous days and
basically previous years as well
is that these two sides uh have uh
conditions
that are unacceptable for the other all
right so thank you very much for
that update from moscow let's now
bring in cinema kosovo she'll give us an
update from azerbaijan
as we're saying the president spoke
earlier on today what was the takeaway
message
well during as you said he said that
this the solution for this problem was
military and
he proved that actually what he said
basically is that
uh in order to bring armenian side to
the table
he had to fight against it he had to
fight
through military means and he says now
it was
the military is a military fight was the
first phase
but also uh diplomacy uh pola politics
are going to work so according to
alhamalia its first military and then
politics and
he said that's how armenians came to
table
and he in a way uh accused
armenia prime minister nicole pacinian
especially because
early earlier in the week he said that
nagorno-karabakh
is an armenian uh is armenian
it belongs to armenia and he said if you
are to repeat this uh
wording again then uh there will be no
talks in moscow
apparently the the initial uh wish for
those they reside is that the armenians
unconditionally withdraw from the
occupied
seven regions adjacent regions
surrounding nagorno-karabakh and then
and talks for nagorno-karabakh will be
in
in place now there are some areas that
the azeri military has already advanced
as uh over through uh some villages of
course but
uh what the foreign ministers who have
been
in direct contact for the first time
since september 20 so what they are
speaking right now and what we will hear
from the pressure is going to be binding
but ill hamalia was so decisive and
determined that
his conditions that armenian forces
withdrawal is necessary for
talks but apparently since they came
around the table
there are some concessions from both
sides
all right senam kosovo thank you very
much